[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
at what is on the front pages time to
see what is making the headlines with
the daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire and the Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine welcome and great to see both
of you uh front pages though first of
all let's start with the Metro uh paying
tribute to the late comedian and
presenter Paul O'Grady saying thanks for
all the joy Paul
that is also the lead story for
tomorrow's Sun as it says goodbye to
Paul and his character Lily Savage
the telegraph says that householders are
to be penalized by the government
through their energy bills if they
refuse to switch away from using gas in
the drive towards net zero the express
reports that the government is to
abandon plans to raise the state pension
age to 68 for fear of alienating middle
aged voters according to the eye Rishi
sunek is facing allegations of a
conflict of interest after it emerged
that a child care firm in which his wife
her shares stands to benefit from his
recently announced budget a spokesperson
for the Prime Minister has insisted the
ministerial code was followed in
addressing the matter
the guardian says the government is
going against expert advice by using
so-called carbon capture technology
where carbon dioxide is acquired and
stored underwater to allow an expansion
of North Sea oil and gas The Daily Mail
leads with a new study claiming the
so-called gender ideology in schools is
putting Children at Risk
the Ft has news that Sergio emoti the
former chief executive of the Investment
Bank UBS has been reappointed to the job
in an effort to ensure its takeover of
the troubled Credit Suisse goes smoothly
and the star
wait for it says the sun is falling to
bits they don't mean their Fleet Street
rival and it could have an impact
bizarrely on Friday I read anyway a
reminder by scanning the QR code you'll
see on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch our guest
let's head straight to Kevin McGuire and
Sarah Vine
um and we start with warnings about AI
front page of the financial times Sarah
musk and a thousand others are deeply
concerned about its impact on society
and Humanity this is absolutely
fascinating
well I think this is this is a story
that's been sort of rambling around for
a bit and it still seems to have
crystallized in this uh announcement by
musk I mean he's got a lot of he's got a
lot of people on side he's got a lot of
he's got the guy from Apple the
co-founder of apple whose name obviously
I forget because I'm not an a bot if I
were a bot I would do it
um and he's but but the idea that you
know chat gbt which is this sort of a
pro AI program that all my daughters
University friends are already using to
write their essays
um is going to it's you know it's it's
it's really terrifying technology in the
sense that it you know I think it was um
I can't remember which bank it was I
think it was Deutsche Bank said that
they thought it would make sort of 300
000 people in their business unemployed
I mean it could have a really huge
social impact because if it supersedes
humans
um in doing these sort of tasks then
what the rest what are we going to do
for the rest of our lives how are we
going to survive
um and I and I think Elon Musk is
actually quite uh quite right to step
forward and sound a warning about it and
say we look we need a kind of considered
approach to this and how how far are we
going to let this go and he says that a
lot of the technology is is not really
properly controlled and the and that
because there's such a sort of Death
Race to come up with the best bit of
technology that uh some companies are
paying playing rather fast and loose
with it yes and listening to experts
about this that the fear is partly that
it can unpick our language which has
taken thousands of years to develop it
can also expose our weaknesses which
we're still trying to cover up ourselves
I suppose
um and Bad actors because you could use
this in terms of issues like security or
deep fakes
um you know stirring up public mood Etc
and I see um by one AI journalist I
follow on Twitter that more than 360 new
AI tools were released in just the last
seven days Kevin so this is an enormous
field is it not
massive and growing and possibly too
little scrutiny in in general uh up
until uh now I've got to get over my
suspicion of Elon Muskie always tries to
resist uh regulation when it uh impacts
on him whether it's Tesla or Twitter and
his own commercial interests so there is
some rivalry here however who controls
operates and benefits from AI is of
crucial importance to us all otherwise
it is very possible it will all just end
up being manipulated and controlled by
it and whoever actually runs it and the
the story of the Industrial Revolution
of course is
your technical change all the time very
very constant uh but is this just a
giant leap so much bigger than many many
before and there has been so little
debate and what regulation is there not
not just in the US but UK and around the
globe so a pause it sounds kind of
sensible doesn't it as you take uh you
know you take stock and where where are
we and what safeguards would be needed
what use could it be put to that's in
the general public good rather than the
the commercial interest or the security
interest or whatever the interest of
those who control it
you know we've seen with social media
what happens when there's zero
regulation I mean so much of the sort of
bad stuff that has happened in recent
years you know free to view hardcore
porn bullying cyber bullying
um all you know the things that we are
all really uncomfortable with have all
been to do with unregulated you know
aren't that that space being completely
unregulated but I think this AI thing
has the potential to make that look like
a walk in the park
yes and I mean ironically this comes as
as the government launches it's AI white
paper to guide the use of artificial
intelligence in the UK to drive
responsible Innovation and maintain
public trust in this revolutionary
technology and certainly
um we've heard in a defense of it in
terms of medical advancements which
could be absolutely critical but I think
everyone's you know feeling slightly
nervous if you if you watch what uh the
latest AI systems can do as you said you
know writing writing essays is just the
tiny part of it isn't it um let's move
on to the guardian an announcement
respecting uh on Thursday uh by Grant
chaps energy and Net Zero secretary
revealing the powering up Britain
strategy with carbon capture and storage
at its heart
um he'll be visiting a nuclear fusion
development facility in Oxford and the
guardian suggests there are concerns
about this then Kevin
yeah according to the guardian uh Grant
chaps will say is going to spend the
government's going to spend 20 billion
over 20 years on capturing carbon
distorting undersea Cavern so we can
exploit more oil and gas Fields there's
a big talk of carbon capture certainly
going back to the 70s and I remember
because it used to be then in relation
to the coal industry which is
essentially being shut down since but it
seems to be the government wants to
expand uh North Sea production of oil
and gas new Fields but at the same time
it's got International commitments on
the environment and reducing the amount
of carbon and this seems to be uh its
answer whether it works or not of course
is where the grid debate uh will be
yes it feels it's probably just better
if we get ourselves off carbon fuels as
quickly as possible yes and after the UK
was host of the cop 26 Summit in Glasgow
you know put huge amounts of effort into
that it's all gone slightly off the boil
presumably because of the Ukraine war
and the energy crisis and therefore the
drive for domestic you know production
of of energy but does the government
need to do more and start to focus and
what can we expect to see in terms of
Net Zero um certainly the telegraph's
talking about penal being penalized
hassles being penalized for using gas in
the future
because I mean there's a sort of
contrasting messages really aren't they
you know on the one hand we're going to
do carbon capture so that we can carry
on using gas and then on the other hand
we're going to be fined if we carry on
using gas so I think there needs to be
perhaps a little bit more joined up
thinking on this I mean I think the the
thing about this situation is that we're
sort of in Uncharted Territory and so a
lot of it is experimental and new and
different and we don't know what if
anything is going to work
um there obviously isn't a silver bullet
so you know they need to they need to
have you know a finger in many pies and
and and follow the you know whatever
gets the results that we need to get in
terms of Net Zero needs to be done more
of but it's difficult it's it's very
difficult and and I do think with the
public do get conflicting messages yes
the telegraph saying ministers are
planning to overhaul subsidy rules so
that gas is relatively less attractive
compared with electricity to drug to try
to drive the uptake of green power and
hate in the end of fossil fuels uh
electricity regarded as Greener because
of its Renewables element certainly
um let's go on to the express Uh Kevin
lots of different papers with different
leads tonight as we can see
um now we've seen what's happened in
France haven't we but the plan to get us
to retire at 68 looks like being shelved
yeah and I think I think this is an easy
up and down story rather than uh you
know um Ai and carbon capture because of
course as a general election looming and
next year and Mel stride the uh working
pensions secretary said now is not the
time to raise retirement age uh the
retirement age again because it's going
up to 67 by 2028 68 within 12 years and
the talk of it going up again after that
I would have thought with an election
looming and uh older people uh Vote or
people thinking to retirement to attend
a vote more than those who are young and
the government's just given a billion
quid to the very richest pensioners I
would have thought announcing you're
going to raise the retirement age for
everybody else ain't gonna go down well
but it's a it's worth noting the French
are on the streets canceling Charlie's
visit uh you know setting buildings of
light smashing Windows over a rise from
62 to 64. so they've got a good compared
to Us in the UK well they say that's the
minimum and many work for longer
um you know there's all sorts of
arguments on the streets of Paris and
elsewhere but certainly the state
pension age was scheduled to rise to 68
by 2046. Mr Hunt had been hoping to
bring forward the increase to the end of
the 2030s as recommended by an
independent review in 2017 and many
people feeling Sarah that actually the
the sort of the growth in our longevity
has stalled and therefore perhaps it's
it's not necessary effectively
is a really interesting idea because I
think if you if you do manual labor then
I don't see how you can possibly carry
on working until the age of 67. I mean
I'm 55 and I'm exhausted already so I
you know I you know and I don't do
manual labor so I think there are you
know there are different different types
of professions require different in
retirement ages I mean the judges I mean
I think all our judges are about 900
years old aren't they they seem to never
retire I think I think that it's it's an
emotive subject I think a lot of people
feel that you know they're worried about
retiring they're worried about not
having enough money they're worried
about their pension not covering the
cost of living etc etc I think a sort of
slightly sort of tiniered we must we
must increase the retirement age it's
just not going to work for the public I
just I I can't see how it would please
anybody
with a pension what it's really about is
when you qualify for your state pension
so every time the government raises it
you know you basically lose nine and a
half Grand or whatever it will be when
you finally get there because in the
private sector or elsewhere there is no
compulsory retirement age now because
that will be huge age discrimination but
being able to get that state pension uh
is a goal for some people when they
think they can actually stop uh working
but uh Sarah read Sarah again is a very
interesting point uh it's almost a
economic class issue on say manual
workers and white collar workers and
it's because well-off people live about
10 years longer than the poorest so
there's actually a case for the state
pension to kick in according to your
economic class and the job you do and if
you're a manual work or a blue collar
work you should be able to get your
pension earlier than somebody who's a
white collar worker because those who
are living 10 years longer the better
off they're getting their pension for an
extra 10 years that must be about an
extra 100 Grand while the poor manual
workers are just about to qualify and
they live a few years and then they're
dead so they don't get to enjoy it so I
think it's the system at the moment
actually benefits the the better off yes
and well you know notwithstanding that
um the pandemic uh and other matters it
is suggested means that uh how long we
live has gone down so a man born in 1971
now expected to live to 83.9 years down
from 85.6 and a woman to 86.7 down from
88.1 so that's quite a significant fall
isn't it in our
what's the opposite of mortality
anyway thank you very much yes that'll
do for now anyway uh no doubt we'll hear
more about that basically thank you very
much indeed oh dear it's late the words
go
um coming up we will take a look at many
of the tributes to the lake comedian and
presenter Paul O'Grady there we are I
can just imagine
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Kevin
McGuire and Sarah Vine
um tributes Kevin all over the
newspapers to Lily Savage Paula Grady
and genuine sadness
um because he provided such Joy joyful
as you listen to him don't you think
oh no absolutely no one has a bad word
for him only a good word because he was
incredibly sharp he was really funny a
terrific nice guy who was very generous
with people a huge heart and he he also
campaigned he cared and because he was
he was campaigning
um for LGBT rights he he was wanting a
police apology for that raid on the
Vauxhall Tavern uh in 1987 and he his
programs about dogs and cats too one in
one appeal no I at 67 when I woke up and
saw you die you know I really felt sad
very very sad he was no he's a wonderful
bloke and he will be really really
missed and only 67 that's no age and
Sarah you were saying you had the
privilege of uh of seeing um Paula Grady
on the student circuit back in the day
and um you know the thing pointing out
that he's just started twice over with
his in know it's it's personality of
Lily Savage and then you know himself
yeah
but he was
I used to steam a lot in the 80s I used
to go to lots of comedy clubs and he was
he was brilliant and but he was
he was really unique I mean nobody was
doing that sort of thing back then and
he did it with such sort of Gusto and
and you know you'd you'd go to to clubs
and you could see that there were a few
people who were a bit you know what's
this I'm not sure about this and within
sort of three minutes he would have the
meeting out of his hand and he had that
brilliant sort of old-fashioned uh comic
thing which is that he he sort of he was
a kind of equal opportunities rude about
everybody so everybody got a little bit
of a tongue lashing and so that was fine
and he was incredibly bright as well
that that's the other thing to say is
that he was just a real sharp cookie and
of course you know that's that's why he
was so successful but like Kevin says in
67 I think he had a bit of a Dicky heart
didn't he I think he'd had a he had a
few problems so I don't know whether
that was what but it does you know you
do think when you're talking about the
retirement age of 68 you know it's not
great is it no absolutely but so many
tributes certainly to her to Paul
O'Grady let's move on to the picture
story that the Daily Telegraph offers
chosen many of course chosen Paul but
they've chosen the Queen the King on his
first state visit to Germany obviously
not France for the reasons we all know
that it was canceled that bit of it and
here he has pictured the king and queen
attending a state banquet at the
Bellevue Palace in Berlin uh hosted by
Frank Volta steinmeyer the German
president and his wife Elka
um Now Kevin I know you're not a
royalist as we know but is it important
do you think for European relations that
these visits take place
yeah it's soft power uh it Schultz uh
raised uh raised brexit you know six
years ago
it was set it was set in motion um so
now I think it really it really does uh
I don't know I think we can we do it in
other ways probably better ways cheaper
ways but if you've got a monarchy you
might as well use it of course we have
you know we have a very European uh
Germanic monarchy until the the first
world war in the middle of it it was uh
you know the house of sax uh Coburg and
gopher that had changed his name to uh
to Windsor so obviously he's relatives
as well doesn't he Sarah
I'm in state dinners are extraordinary
occasions they're sort of mad completely
Bonkers I actually went to one once and
it was the maddest evening of My Life
um they're very formal uh everything is
everything is done within sort of very
clear sort of tight parameters so
there's no margin for error and they
they do I mean they do achieve what what
they're meant to achieve which is that
they make the guests feel very valued
and and and you know fated I suppose
that and I think this particular I mean
it's a shame that he didn't get to go to
France because I do think that uh you
know rebuilding a few Bridges with our
European neighbors is not a bad idea and
I think he's probably just the right man
to do it
thank you very much indeed